obviously the big thing was the second
in by indictment the first one was a
couple months ago in New York this one
was at a federal courthouse here in
Miami as I said repeatedly this week it
had nothing to do with the state of
Florida there were Federal courthouses
in every state in the Union uh here is
Trump's attorney uh after the indictment
uh her name's Alina hababa talking about
the Biden Department of Justice
Joe Biden himself
retained possession of classified
documents that have not been prosecuted
[Music]
and none of them came into possession of
those documents while they were
president
none of them were president who as the
head and sole member of the executive
branch
has the power to summarily declassify
documents
the decision to pursue charges against
President Trump while turning a blind
eye to others
is emblematic of the corruption that we
have here
we are at a turning point in our
nation's history
the targeting prosecution
of a leading political opponent
is the type of thing you see in
dictatorships like Cuba and Venezuela
it is commonplace there for rival
candidates to be prosecuted persecuted
and put into jail
what is being done to the president
Trump
should terrify all citizens of this
country
these are not the ideas that our
democracy is founded upon
this is not our America
all right so to be clear uh she is
telling the truth there in that Biden
was found with classified documents he
was a VP at the time and VPS do not have
the right to declassify Mike Pence same
exact thing we don't even have to get
into all the things that Hillary did
with bleach bit and all the rest of it
destroying hard drives
Etc
um Amy just on that front is is that the
thing that people are most focused on
this sort of selective enforcement of
the law because I we can get into some
of the stuff in the indictment and it
does sound like Trump did some fairly
stupid things at least uh but that's
very secondary to the to the selective
portion of this yeah I mean I think
there's two different two different
things here right I mean I think he
actually did some stuff that was
probably wrong and then there's the the
two tiers of Justice part of this right
where there's you know Republicans or he
actually faces severe consequences
because it's a Witch Hunt for him
because they've been wanting I mean
there are people look at Keith olberman
wants him to die for crying out loud I
mean it's like this is if they've been
on a Witch Hunt for him since day one
they absolutely hate this guy and
they're doing a lot of things out of
just severe hatred for Trump I think we
all know that and then there's the part
where he did some stuff that was wrong
so when he gets into that courtroom
they're going to be you know putting him
on trial trial for the things that he
did not hey what did what did Joe Biden
face or not face what did Hillary
Clinton face or not face I mean it's
going to be the the things that that
Donald Trump did so he can't really use
in his defense well what Joe Biden
didn't face it and Hillary Clinton
didn't face it so he's going to have to
actually face the music for the things
that he did now do I think it's
completely unfair yeah and I think that
everybody in this country is at least
conservatives
um people on our the right side of the
aisle are looking at this and saying
this is a Witch Hunt yeah and I hope
that at the end of the day if he is
um convicted of you know criminal stuff
wrongdoing that whoever is President and
if that president is a republican
um that they pardon him I hope they do
that I hope that we all agree or at
least they agree they come together and
somebody will pardon him rally yeah I
agree I suspect that any Republican
would because it would help with some of
the healing and if it is another
Republican most likely the Santa's like
you're going to need some Maga DeSantis
healing so I think that hopefully they
would